hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
lara croft and this is Laura just saw
Tamra just saw I wish I just saw the new
reboot of Tomb Raider and I have some
feelings about it first of all where
were her pixel boobs
her boobs weren't even big oh yeah she
was perfect for the character and she
was perfect in every way and it worked
so well by I saw some people like very
upset about her boobs on Twitter and I
think that's so funny it is a big part
of her kind of look original Lara Croft
growing up the first few games was very
sexualized and so I understand that
something that you think about when you
think about that character but I loved
this actress in this role what was her
name who was she Alison Alicia vikander
I don't know how to say that but I
absolutely loved her there won't be any
like heavy spoilers because there's a
few things you could spoil in this film
that really threw me for a loop honestly
I don't know how I feel about it I think
good but it was weird really good review
to me I really loved thank Julie
Mitchell erosions I know there's silly
as hell and I realize that they're not
like incredible movies but I love them
so much
Laura was one of my very first female
role models as a child I used to play
the original games with my dad and that
was when the internet wasn't around and
there we didn't have the guides so if
you couldn't get past a part in the
video game you had to call this like
1-800 number and pay to learn how to get
past this like hard puzzle it's just
crazy to think about that now when you
can be like oh I can't get past this
core Ock and breadth of the wild let me
just do poop on my phone Clorox seeds
aren't hard to get that was a terrible
example but you know what I mean and
then a new game came out I was gonna
show it on screen but I'm actually
lending it to Malcolm right now and then
I really enjoyed it showed Lara a bit
less sexualized it showed the
relationship with her dad really well
and there's a lot more story to it this
movie did such a good job of portraying
this new video game the Angelina Jolie
ones were definitely more the original
games this one was almost like shot by
shot the the newer reboot of the
videogame and I loved it I don't know
that I've ever felt that way about a
video game movie ever I don't think I've
ever seen a video game movie and felt
wow that really portrayed something that
I loved to play and loves to interact
with and to see it on a big screen was
just so exciting if you love the
franchise if you love the games you are
going to really enjoy this movie there
were some weird CGI things that were
going on that just looked bad they did
do a few things with the character that
I feel could have been improved upon
there's the big trope where at the
beginning of a movie you see the strong
independent character you know who's
gonna rise to the top at the end but at
the very beginning they're in a fight
and they're probably boxing so that's
usually what's happening it wasn't this
film they're boxing and they're back to
you with someone else and the other
person wins and it's like oh man they
have a long way to go and it's like this
is Lara Croft like how was she supposed
to find him Eko if she can't win a
boxing match I've said it once I'll say
it a thousand times there was a few
times where something in the beginning
happened and then something exactly the
same happened later on and she overcomes
it because she learned from it it's like
okay well we've seen that a million
times it could have been an even more
interesting action film than it was
there were though a few sequences that
really surprised me and I will get into
those when the time comes just chill I
do love what they do with the character
in that she is not what you think of
when you think of Lara Croft in the
beginning it doesn't seem like she has a
giant fortune she is a bike courier
she's delivering snacks to people as
she's scraping by trying to get money
wherever she can she doesn't feel that
she's entitled to the fortune that her
father left he's been missing for about
seven years presumably dead and she is
just trying to make it on her own i I
really enjoy what they did with that
part of her character later on it comes
up like what university did you go to
and she's like actually I didn't go to
university I just
I like that it's more relatable I guess
because I didn't go to university and I
want to be Lara Croft so thank you movie
they introduced the origin of her green
necklace that was in the recent video
games which I need to get and it's on my
Amazon wishlist so you know it's to also
in the necklace origin scene you get to
see Nick Frost he's in this film and I
was so delighted by that and when it
happened I just thought to myself wow
Thank You Tamra's never seen Thank You
Channel awesome because my goodness I
know who Nick Frost its she's such a
killer actress she got the exact tone
and attitude and brilliance of Laura but
just the attitude really got me I felt
like the angelina jolie movies wow i
love them and i loved her as that role i
thought she was perfect for the time was
it you know the lara croft i remember
playing in video games or like that i
imagined for myself that she was like it
was very like tongue-in-cheek like very
silly kind of very i don't know not not
the seriousness and brilliance but also
a sense of comedy and also a sense of
like you know you kind of like I just
she got it perfectly and she was so good
and I really believed things she was
saying in like a Tomb Raider film that
overall was kind of silly and could have
been a lot better I still felt like she
was a really killer actress so her
father goes missing and he's been gone
for a very long time and she finally
after seven years unlocks the mystery to
where he's been and could possibly still
be and so she goes to Hong Kong she goes
to find him Eko the queen of death
she's like a super cool name
she got to Hong Kong and there's the
scene of these three thieves trying to
steal her bag and she does some really
cool maneuvering to get her bag back
then they're gonna try to cut off her
tongue and she did some really really
good work to get away from them but then
at the end she still needs help from a
drunken fisherman and it's like I wish
you could have just done that
self I don't feel like she needed all
the help that she got in this film but
the drunken fisherman ends up being the
son of the man who initially took her
father out to see him ago and so they go
wow what a coincidence if you played the
video game you know about this scene
there's a scene where the boat is
sinking that is taking them to him ago
and it is an exciting sequence this is
what I was talking about the beginning
the sheer awesomeness of the boat
sinking scene if you've played the video
game you know the one was so incredible
I was immediately put in the mood it's
badassery was deeply erotic is what I
was scribbling down in the movie theater
I meant it
and then after this pretty much
word-for-word it's the video game there
is a bad guy named Matthias she gets
taken prisoner and then she escapes in a
very badass way with the help of her
very badass attractive friend
and it looks so much like the game and
as a gamer who played the game that's
super exciting something I've been never
experienced before the airplane
waterfalls see moi yes and I wrote out
my so I knew I knew in my mind what I
wanted for that moment I wrote in the
him ago tube amazing so Tomb Raider so
much cooler than Angelina Jolie though I
do think something they got really right
with Angelina Jolie one is that she
believes in magic and the mystical and
the unknown like she's an archaeologist
but also very much that like she
believes in things that a lot of
archaeologists don't believe in maybe I
don't know what they believe in but it
just seems like she believed in magic
and the Angelina Jolie one and it's kind
of fun to see that in this one she's
very skeptical of that but again that's
because she's playing a younger version
of herself hopefully now from here on
out she will she has two magic happens
magic the game they just sit around the
tomb and play magic doesn't sound
interesting but it was in this film you
get to see some things out of the
character and her relationship with
people that she's close with that you've
never seen before and I think that's
really cool I cried in the end
I cried at a Tomb Raider film cried
everything I wrote I wish they would
have had her kick even more ass she
needed assistance many times and the
character and the actor deserved better
I think this actress portrayed her so
well the character of someone that I so
look up to and so loved so much
obviously and so I wanted her to even do
more and I think if they continue on
with the character that's something that
they're gonna have to work on the setup
for the second one though it was amazing
she goes back to Nick Frost's pawn shop
deal and she sees the gun and she's like
I like it I'll take two and then that's
it that's all the reason I love it so
much I like it I'll take two all in all
I think it was a really fun game or like
I said if you are into the franchise of
Tomb Raider if you love Laura Croft like
I do you're gonna have a really good
time with this film definite problems
absolutely but overall I thought it was
so good let me know what you think about
it in the comments below and I will see
you all next week
bye I like it I love it I want some more
of it ah
[Music]